[Musique]
en trop c'est le titre de ce spectacle
de la danse hip hop contemporaine pour
raconter deux thèmes de l'introspection
sur scène trois femmes un dialogue
danser parfois synchronisée mais
toujours en gardant les singularités
propres à chacune c'est vraiment mal à
la mise en geste de
d'individualités qui ont leurs
singularités qui ont leurs
particularités de d'être et du coup
c'est globalement un unis sow qui se
transforme et qui est très teintée de
chacune de sa personnalité et dans un
face à face avec le public un trophée
référence aussi aux thermes introduction
c'est le premier spectacle de la
chorégraphe mélina boubetra
[Musique]
j'aime travailler vraiment le corps et
que
je crois que pour recréer c'est ce qui
me va le mieux de vraiment travailler
avec les personnes et voir ce qu elle ce
qu'elle porte et ce qu'elles ont envie
de lâcher aussi con ce spectacle d'une
durée de 30 minutes s'inscrit dans la
neuvième édition du festival calypso qui
prône la création chorégraphique hip hop
de nombreux événements culturels sont
programmées dans 31 lieux de la région
ile-de-france sur le territoire grand
paris seine et oise 5 actions
culturelles sont proposées ça permet
d'avoir un maillage un petit peu du
territoire francilien de mettre en
valeur la création chorégraphique hip
hop sur ce territoire et
particulièrement sur le territoire de la
communauté urbaine gps et au vendredi 3
décembre le festival sur le territoire
yvelinois se clôturera avec la compagnie
mazel frétel qui jouera son spectacle
perception au conservatoire à
rayonnement départemental de gps et au
manque la jolie